the judge will actually collaborate with
the government in coming up with
hypothetical justifications for a law in
order to bend over backwards and uphold
whatever the government is doing so no
you don't get a neutral arbiter hi I'm
Zach Weiss Mulder with reason TV i'm
here with clark Neely he's a senior
attorney at the Institute for justice
and author of the new book terms of
engagement how the courts should enforce
the Constitution's promise of limited
government Clark thank you very much for
talking with us my pleasure thanks for
having me you open the book by talking a
lot about judicial activism and it's a
charge levelled by both the left and the
right often by the right when it's
something they don't like such as a
court ruling in favor of gay marriage or
the left when perhaps the court's ruling
in favor of political speech like the
Citizens United case you talk about not
judicial activism but judicial
engagement judicial activism is
completely overblown in comparison to
the much more serious problem of
judicial abdication and by that I mean
the systemic failure of judges to
genuinely enforce constitutional limits
on government power the opposite of
judicial abdication is judicial
engagement which means it's a sincere
effort on the part of the judges to
enforce constitutional limits on
government power you kind of identify
the point where things went wrong is
when the judiciary started embracing the
rational basis test could you explain
briefly what that is and what's wrong
with it so the rational basis test was
essentially invented during the
progressive movement and really came
into use in the the New Deal when the
courts decided that essentially they
wanted to throw the doctrine of
federalism in other words the idea of a
federal government with limited and
enumerated powers they wanted to throw
that off the back of the constitutional
sled and they also wanted to give the
government a free pass to regulate in
the economy for any reason or no reason
so they invented this thing called the
rational basis test which is actually
none of those things and what it
requires courts to do is essentially
invent justifications for government
regulation even when those
justifications have nothing to do with
the law under review and I just consider
it
to be a paradigmatic example of judicial
abdication the opposite of which which I
already for in the book is judicial
engagement the problem that critics seem
to have with judicial engagement is that
they see it as the judiciary overriding
the will of the people often because
these things have been passed
democratically and then a judge is
swooping in and saying no you this is
not constitutional how do you respond to
that you have a problem with democracy
isn't democracy a good thing democracy
is a good thing in comparison to other
systems of government like
totalitarianism but it is not an
unfettered good and we don't have a pure
democracy in this country we have a
constitutional republic the Constitution
establishes that there are some things
the government may not do and I'll give
you one example that I think most people
respond to in the 20th century more than
half of the states in this country had
laws regarding eugenic sterilization and
we as a country sterilized more than
60,000 people most of them young
minority women I don't think anybody is
going to sit here and say well you know
that's the will of the people and if
those women don't want to be sterilized
they should just go lobby the government
to change that law no we have a
constitution to prevent that kind of
thing and thank goodness an important
part of your argument rests on the
philosophical notion as your kind of
alluding to that individuals have rights
outside of those that are specifically
listed in the Constitution outside of
free speech you know the right to bear
arms there are unenumerated rights where
do you get that idea the idea that the
Constitution contains unenumerated
rights traces right back to the text of
the Constitution so the 9th amendment
specifically says that the enumeration
in the constitution of certain rights
shall not be construed to deny or
disparage other rights retained by the
people this is a clear textual
indication of the existence of onion
umer ated rights this is reinforced by a
provision of the 14th amendment which
was ratified in 1868 to try to help
stamp out the evils of Jim Crow during
the Reconstruction that the privileges
or immunities of citizens of the United
States are not to be infringed by the
states that is a clear reference to
unenumerated rights and
really the only question is what are
they I mentioned one before which is the
right not to be sterilized by the
government for nakedly eugenic purposes
there are others of course and they
would include the right to our living
enter into contracts you identified two
very specific textual examples the 9th
amendment privileges and immunities
clause I've personally never heard the
Ninth Amendment referenced in for
instance a Supreme Court ruling are
these things being ignored by our
judiciary they are being adore the Ninth
Amendment and the fourteenth amendments
privileges or immunities Clause are
systematically ignored by the judiciary
treated as if they didn't exist in the
famous words of now deceased Judge
Robert Bork they are mere inkblots in
the Constitution I think that is a
terribly disrespectful way to approach
the Constitution every part of the
Constitution is meaningful including the
parts that clearly protect onion umer
ated rights like the 9th amendment in
the fourteenth amendments privileges or
immunities Clause inquiry to ignore
those provisions even though they do
you're a working attorney with the
Institute for justice which is a great
organization and everyone should check
it out we'll put up a link so that
everyone can look at it you've seen this
erosion of rights up close and personal
in the courtroom I'm sure the bias that
the court has towards the state what are
some of the examples you've run into in
your own practice it's very difficult to
litigate a rational basis case for
example where you are trying to
vindicate somebody's right whether it's
to earn a living in the occupation of
their choice not to have their home
bulldoze simply to give it to somebody
to build a nicer home because the courts
are so unremittingly pro-government in
these cases and one example that really
stands out for me is when a federal
judge in the state of Louisiana upheld
as a legitimate regulation the Louisiana
law that requires people have a florist
license just to sell floral arrangements
this had a terrible consequence for our
lead client sandy meadows because she
was a widow and a high school dropout
whose only vocational skill was making
floral arrangements and when the state
put her out of business as they did
because she couldn't pass the completely
subjective and arbitrary licensing exam
she was unemployed and she died a few
months later alone
and in poverty because the state of
Louisiana took away her ability to earn
a living in a harmless occupation and I
couldn't persuade a judge to protect her
constitutional right to do that work and
it was it really it was really sad day
from here really ugly sad day judges are
supposed to act as neutral arbiters you
know disinterested third parties when it
comes to a conflict between an
individual and the state is that the
case in America today well it is
sometimes the case that judges act as
neutral arbiters they do so in the
context of rights that the Supreme Court
has deemed fundamental which is simply
constitutional euphemism for important
enough to enforce in a meaningful way
unfortunately that is not the default
setting of our courts the default
setting is that most rights the right to
earn living to own property to eat what
you want to take medicine that you want
all of these are considered to be non
fundamental rights by the court and
therefore not entitled to any meaningful
level of judicial protection instead
they get rational basis review where the
judge will actually collaborate with the
government in coming up with
hypothetical justifications for a law in
order to bend over backwards and uphold
whatever the government is doing so no
you don't get a neutral arbiter in these
so-called non fundamental rights cases
what you essentially get is two
advocates one working for the executive
branch and the other working for the
judiciary who together work together to
come up with a justification for the law
regardless of its true constitutionality
and I think that has to change all of
this rests upon the idea that the
Constitution matters it was written
hundreds of years ago by dead guys who
wore powdered wigs what gives the
constitutional legitimacy and why does
it matter in 2014 in a nutshell I would
say this it's no accident that the US
Constitution is the longest-running
Constitution of any major country in the
world and I think it's because of its
inherent moral legitimacy it's not
perfect but it's about the best that
anybody has ever done and as Randy
Barnett argues in his book restoring the
lost Constitution our Constitution is
binding in conscience because it so
often gets the important questions right
that government should be limited that
individual rights should be respected
and that
government should have to justify its
incursions of liberty to the individual
and not the other way around but
unfortunately the judiciary in the last
80 years or so has completely inverted
that order of values and what we need to
do is to get it back so that the courts
are applying the Constitution the way it
was intended as a bulwark of liberty and
not as a blueprint for the exercise of
government power which is how they treat
it now Clark neely thank you very much
for talking with us it's been my
pleasure thanks for having me for a
reason TV I'm Zack why smaller